[Musica]
suo figlio non sta mai fermo
parla in continuazione disturba e
compagni queste erano le tipiche frasi
che i miei genitori si sentivano dire
ogni volta che andavano al ricevimento
dei professori al liceo in classe non
amavo molto simili le elezioni mi
distraevo facilmente diciamo che il mio
interesse nei confronti delle varie
materie ma piuttosto scarso tutto
cambiava quando arrivava la lezione di
fisica eccoli mi incantavo l'idea di
conoscere le leggi che governano il
mondo che mi circonda mi affascina
mi sembra di avere in mano il libretto
delle istruzioni della natura certo al
liceo non si hanno gli strumenti ancora
per comprendere a fondo quelle leggi
bisogna fare un po un atto di fede
bisogna crederci è questa cosa non è che
mi sia mai andata particolarmente a
genio tant'è vero che quando il
professore introduceva un nuovo
argomento io mi trovavo spesso a dire ma
siamo proprio sicuri sicuri che sia così
lui ovviamente si arrabbiava diceva si è
così non puoi capire credici
effettivamente aveva anche ragione ma
questo tipo di approccio ovvero di
fiducia incondizionata
incontestabile nei confronti dei
cosiddetti sapienti ha dominato il mondo
della cultura per quasi duemila anni
bisogna infatti tornare indietro al 300
avanti cristo per trovare il più grande
influencer della storia dell'umanità
aristotele da siracusa di cui approccio
alla conta alla scienza infatti non
prevedeva la possibilità di venire
contraddetto nella sua scuola infatti
lui diceva che i sapienti devono
lavorare da soli non devono confrontarsi
con gli altri non devono permettere a
nessuno di contestare le proprie idee
che quindi sono delle verità assolute e
soprattutto non davano fare esperimenti
perché lo scienziato non si sporca le
mani grazie a questo approccio nel suo
trattato fisica sosteneva che la terra
fosse al centro dell'universo il sole
gli altri pianeti niro tasse rowe
intorno questa affermazione falsa si è
mantenuta in realtà vera per quasi venti
secoli
l'approccio aristotelico ha gettato una
vera e propria ombra nel mondo della
cultura una sovrastruttura che ha
impedito al pensiero scientifico di
evolvere serviranno menti capaci di
pensare fuori dagli schemi per
soverchiare queste sovrastrutture
in grado di enormi sacrifici come ben sa
il giordano bruno bruciato vivo il 17
febbraio del 1600 a campo dei fiori roma
per aver sostenuto fra le altre cose che
l'alba il tramonto non solo la
dimostrazione che il sole gira intorno
alla terra ma l'esatto contrario
ma ormai la situazione stava mutando
inizi del seicento cominciava a venire
fuori un nuovo metodo che prendeva
sempre più piede grazie a una delle
menti più rivoluzionarie del pensiero
scientifico galileo galilei che infatti
introdurrà il metodo scientifico il suo
approccio non prevede una verità
assoluta anzi prevede che tutte le idee
possono venire contestate da altri
scrive in volgare per permettere al
popolo di poter comprendere ciò che dice
e partecipare alla discussione
grazie al suo approccio galileo
svilupperà il cannocchiale che era già
stato inventato qualche anno prima in
olanda e riuscirà a osservare i
satelliti di giove le fasi di tenere ea
dimostrare finalmente che l'idea della
terra al centro dell'universo fosse
un'idea sbagliata il mezzo scientifico
mi esalta e allora ha deciso di
iscrivermi all'università facoltà di
fisica dopo aver cominciato a studiare
la cosiddetta fisica classica ovvero la
fisica che si studia chi sia stata
scoperta diciamo fra inizi del novecento
mi accorgo che tutto è ben determinato
tutto segue la logica della vita di
tutti i giorni posso finalmente
spingermi verso ciò che più che più mi
appassiona l'infinitamente piccolo il
mondo degli atomi e delle molecole posso
finalmente capire tutto
una delusione micidiale non si capiva
nulla tutto quello che aveva studiato
fino allora non funzionava più nel mondo
dell'infinitamente piccolo i sensi non
bastano
quindi diciamo era necessario fare
qualcosa in più era necessario di nuovo
fare un passo avanti
serviranno menti eccellenti e
completamente visionarie come quelle di
heisenberg di paoli di dirac agli inizi
del 900 per introdurre un nuovo metodo
atto a soverchiare queste sovrastrutture
ed è lì che ho capito quale del problema
ho capito che una delle grandi
sovrastrutture da superare era che
l'uomo crede che tutto sia come ci
appare che la logica e la vita di tutti
i giorni sia nei sensi di tutti i giorni
siano sufficienti a comprendere tutto
nell'infinitamente piccolo così non è
eyes and bear paulig dirac daranno un
passo in avanti entro dovranno un metodo
completamente diverso che prende il nome
di meccanica quantistica la meccanica
quantistica è un approccio che consente
di spiegare tutto quello che accade
nell'infinitamente piccolo e che
apparentemente impossibile
seguendo la logica della vita di tutti i
giorni vi faccio faccio un esempio sarà
capitato con la macchina di trovarvi di
fronte a un bivio di non sapere se
andare a sinistra oa destra ecco un
elettrone le medesime condizioni non si
pone un problema e passa
contemporaneamente da entrambe le parti
si parla di dualismo onda corpuscolo
oppure siete in auto girate per una
strada vi trovate di fronte a un
cancello chiuso vicolo cieco
dovete tornare indietro un elettrone
invece sa che per lui esiste una
probabilità non nulla di esistere anche
dall'altra parte del cancello pack ci
passa attraverso si dice effetto tunnel
oppure se in un circuito di formula 1
posizionata una fotocellula era un punto
potete sapere esattamente in quel punto
la velocità della macchina che ci sta
passando attraverso di nuovo per un
elettrone non è così se sapete dov'è
non sapete quanto si muove velocemente
se conoscete la sua velocità non saprete
mai dove sia
questo si chiama principio di
indeterminazione
ed è questa la principale differenza fra
fisica classica e meccanica quantistica
in fisica classica tutto è ben
determinato potete misurare tutti i
parametri del vostro sistema e sapere
esattamente dove si trovava prima della
vostra misura
il meccanica quantistica invece potete
sapere solo con quale probabilità il
vostro sistema evolva in una direzione
piuttosto che in un'altra e quando
andate voi a fare la misura che ne
determinate lo stato finale ma perdendo
completamente informazione di come fosse
prima del vostro intervento non potete
saperlo mai in questa cosa mandava in
bestia einstein ma alla fine anche lui
ha dovuto accettarlo la meccanica
quantistica in realtà spiega anche una
ricaduta anche nella vita di tutti i
giorni spiega anche degli effetti reali
e in particolare ha contribuito allo
sviluppo della più importante invenzione
della storia dell'umanità la lavatrice
la lavatrice in particolare
l'elettronica all'interno della
lavatrice così come l'elettronica
all'interno degli smartphone dei
televisori dei computer si basa
esclusivamente sulla meccanica
quantistica
niente meccanica quantistica
niente elettronica e ci ritroveremo
tutti a lavare a mano i nostri panni al
fiume
elettronica alla base della società
moderna che richiede computer sempre più
potenti sempre più veloci sempre più
efficaci per far questo è necessario
prendere il cervello del computer il
cosiddetto microchip e inserirci dentro
il maggior numero di elementi capaci di
fare calcoli i cosiddetti transistor è
il modo per metterci sempre più
transistor e renderli sempre più piccoli
ma la meccanica quantistica che spiega
il funzionamento di un transistor ne
limita anche la sua miniaturizzazione
infatti dovete pensare a un transistor
come a un canale in cui scorre un fiume
di elettroni in questo canale via un
cancello se il cancello è chiuso gli
elettroni non passano stato logico 0 se
il cancello è aperto gli elettroni
passano stato logico 1 insieme di uno e
zero formano il cosiddetto beat che alla
base del calcolo dei computer ora se
cominciate a ridurre questo transistor è
cominciato a farlo sempre sempre più
piccolo fino ad arrivare a una
dimensione di cinque nanometri ovvero 5
milionesimi di millimetro e questo già
si fa nell'industria
ecco in quelli infinitamente piccolo la
meccanica quantistica la fa da padrona
quindi ritorna di nuovo l'effetto tunnel
di cui sopra il cancello sia aperto che
il cancello sia chiuso l'elettrone se ne
frega e ci passa comunque attraverso
quindi non c'è più distinzione fra stato
logico uno è stato logico 0 il
transistor cessa di funzionare
l'elettronica non può più evolvere ma
quel limite già stato raggiunto
non c'è margine per l'elettronica di
poter andare avanti
ma la meccanica quantistica toglie la
meccanica quantistica da esiste un'altra
proprietà dell'elettrone spiegabile solo
attraverso la meccanica quantistica che
è la sua capacità di ruotare intorno al
proprio asse come fa un pianeta ruota in
un verso parleremo di spin up spin e la
proprietà di ruotare intorno al proprio
asse se ruota dall altra parte
chiameremo spin da ora supponete di
poter strutturare il vostro transistor
non attraverso un flusso continuo di
elettroni ma semplicemente facendoli
ruotare intorno a se stessi 6 ruotano
tutti da un lato tutti spina stato
logico uno show ruotano tutti dall'altro
stato logico
01 spin un transistor basato su un
concetto di meccanica quantistica prende
il nome di transistor hobbit quantistico
o più fitte ora il problema dell'effetto
tunnel non si pone più perché di
elettroni non si devono più muovere
quindi potete rimini a utilizzarli in
quanto volete
inoltre far cambiare il verso di
rotazione da una parte o dall'altra
degli elettroni è molto più veloce e
costa molto meno energia che farli
fruttare tutti insieme ecco un
dispositivo più veloce più potente e che
consuma di meno la branca della fisica
che studia gli effetti dello spin prende
il nome di spintronica ed è arrivata a
cinquant'anni di distanza dall
invenzione dell'elettronica il primo
passo è il primo grande massa accaduto
dopo duemila anni con la meccanica
quantistica dopo 300 con la spintronica
dopo 50 i grandi passi le grandi
evoluzioni della scienza avvengono a
passi sempre più ravvicinati grazie alla
condivisione delle informazioni da parte
dell'intera comunità mondiale la
spintronica quindi alla possibilità di
superare i limiti dell'elettronica e di
andare verso la costruzione di quello
che si chiama il computer quantistico
ovvero un computer basato non su beat
classici ma subìte quantistici
un computer che sarebbe in grado di fare
in 20 secondi
quello che gli attuali supercomputer
riuscirebbero a fare in 600 anni
la cosiddetta supremazia quantistica
ovvero il passaggio da un computer
classico a un computer quantistico è
ancora lontana dall'essere raggiunta ma
è l'ennesimo esempio in cui menti capaci
di pensare fuori dagli schemi hanno
permesso di superare gli attuali limiti
del pensiero e della tecnologia
menti capaci di utilizzare la fantasia
come elemento portante dei propri
ragionamenti
caratteristiche a questa tipica della
mente dei bambini quindi se vostro
figlio o vostro nipote a scuola si
distrae ha sempre la testa fra le nuvole
non necessariamente a un disturbo
dell'attenzione o come me magari un po
svogliato forse sta semplicemente
liberando la propria fantasia
permettendo la propria mente di superare
da domani le ombre le sovrastrutture
dell'oggi
no se guidatelo grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]